am 19 august 2012 wütete ein großbrand
auf dem ehemaligen saurer areal in arbon
am bodensee über die unmittelbaren
folgen des infernos auf den unternehmer
peter haag berichteten wir vor einer
woche seine großhandelsfirma für holz
brannte bis auf die grundmauern nieder
die schadenhöhe 2,2 millionen franken
nach unglaublich vor allem darf
dabei haben zu verstehende verbrauch die
polizei stellte fest dass der brand an
der fassade verlags betrieb ausgebrochen
war
ich meine vor der ursache hatte ein
brand legte die eurobahn stiftet wenn
man jetzt die frage genauer aus der
offizielen das natürlich auch nicht böse
aber wie ich selber vergangen hat er
wirklich mit dem brandausbruch also was
ich unter brandstifter sie der verdacht
auf brandstiftung konnte nicht erhärtet
werden
was der auslöser des feuers war bleibt
bis heute ungeklärt haag fand trost und
kraft bei der familie zu hause
der unternehmer entschied sich seinen
betrieb wieder aufzubauen der die sechs
mitarbeiter und seine lebenspartnerin
marianne knöpfe bezogen ein notebook
mitte september konnte der unternehmer
seine kunden nicht mehr ausreichend mit
holz beliefern der firma fehlte ein
warenlager schlimmsten fall wenn man
reduzieren einfach unglaublich
schwierige situation
[Musik]
in den ersten tagen des oktobers 2012
werden die verkohlten überreste entsorgt
wirkung richtig genial
jetzt lautet dort richtig versteht sehr
es alle sein trikot
da ich wegen der guten richtigen worden
kollegen aus ganz arbon helfen dem
unternehmer bei der räumung
zwei lange wochen liegen hinter peter
haag während denen er nicht wusste ob er
seinen betrieb einstellen muss also
wieso ist jetzt möglich zurück es ist
einiges ändern grünen das material farbe
polizei ist ja schon länger breiter
woche frei gehe und dass jetzt noch
sieben rechtsproblem thomas fähigkeit
nicht wenn diese überhaupt gelesen hat
dann auch so wichtig ist im mai zum
glauben vor dass man endlich eine fesche
machen
möglichst rasch soll nun an dieser
stelle ein zelt aufgestellt werden um
wieder ein war endlager zu haben nur mit
einem magazin kann die großhandelsfirma
für holz weitermachen
[Musik]
mitte oktober steht die provisorische
lagerhalle der firma leimholz ag endlich
kann haag seine kunden wieder mit holz
beliefern
trotzdem es gibt neuen ärger
seit das zelt steht muss der betrieb
monatlich 2000 franken mehr miete
bezahlen
ja das war der größere problem das wir
natürlich jetzt sehr sehr dürren platz
sind also mehr zahlen die jetzt erzählt
weiter voran wo man not a la carte
besucht dann ja da schreibt versuch von
formiert bereit auch mehr informiert
heute bestimmen und mehr ins sagt er
aber es hunderte auch dazu an im
internet das land habe neben java
sämtliche baute haase die große zelt
die ganze infrastruktur auch widerrufbar
halt ich viel darauf ankommen die
immobilien firma hrs ist besitzerin des
areals in arbon sie ertrags mietzins von
10.000 auf 12000 franken erhöht hans
meyer ist zuständig für die mietverträge
der treuhänder rechtfertigt sich weshalb
die hrs mehr geld verlangt daher hat
bisher alle quält ein objekt beiden
jetzt ins grab
die halle ist komplett zerstört mit der
total schade ist im mietvertrag
untergang
er hat neun grundstücke also flächen
beansprucht sehr viel mehr flächen azubi
serie hat mir halt mit ihnen flächen
brisant macht erhält oder in
provisorische zelte aufgestellt also von
noemi zinshöhe kann man erzählte sich
ein komplett anderes mädchen ist total
andere mietobjekten
zusammen mit dem zelt und im not büro
beansprucht die leimholz ag rund 400
quadratmeter mehr als zuvor
dafür aber gleich einen aufpreis von
2000 franken zu verlangen findet tag
ungerecht
wer jetzt allerdings definitiv zurück da
bin ich ganz sicher aber es
selbstverständlich weiß der familie dass
mehrere schwierige situation gehabt bei
andere möglichkeiten der chef der
großhandelsfirma fühlt sich ausgenutzt
und will mit seiner firma das saure
areal verlassen mitarbeiter lukas keller
begleitet den unternehmer in die
nachbargemeinde steinach dort hat tag
einen neuen standort im visier
also frei steht letztlich seite zeigen
dafür damit die übernahme bis zur grenze
geführt und auch nicht in den elitären
entlang
bereits hat der architekt einen entwurf
des geplanten gebäudes gemacht
noch hat der großhändler das bauland
nicht erworben
dafür braucht es geld viel geld hat muss
zwei millionen eigenkapital aufbringen
die bank soll den restbetrag übernehmen
hofft er
jonas nick liefern der thurgauer
kantonalbank ist seit jahren seien
kundenberater baustoff ratschlag mich
braucht bin ich da was das ausmaß der
fag die zusammenstellung der total
betrag von rund 8 8 millionen massiv
grundstück db sowie das ergibt ein
grundstück quartal auf als sie das nach
linie geht dass man auch etwas mehr als
zwei wochen mutterschutz dauern klären
ob diese hoch ist aber wenn man sich
gegen verbale retourkutsche präsentiert
xenos wird massiv investiert unsere ganz
klar kapazitätssteigerung gegenüber dem
motto gesetzt also erster linie
natürlich dass man da einfach
unglaublich groß das materiallager als
größte rohmaterialien gelagert ist und
wo mir natürlich viel schlagkräftiger
wäre bringt dir eine halbschranke
irgendwie als objekt so wenn sie mich
aus miteinander besprachen hält seine
hand finanziert
der schritt die entwicklung wieder zu
machen
[Musik]
im november steht das gespann auch die
bank hat inzwischen die hypothek des 8,8
millionen teuren neubaus gewährt
was jetzt noch fehlt ist die
baubewilligung heute präsentiert haag im
gemeindehaus steinach den behörden das
projekt war möchte mehr deutsche
nahsicht druff eigentliche situations
plan mit dem hochregallager 30 mal 40
meter risch und 16 meter hoch und daher
heimann als bürogebäude mit dem blick
eigentlich denn da direkt auf der
betrieb an
architekt hans peter frey ist etwas
nervös
er hofft dass die mühlen der behörden
rascher malen als sonst da immer so
bewegung bewirkt dass man künftig
dezentral in den verhören
das ist eine ganz normale feier ins
kantoren hund tag führt
bewilligungspflicht erwarten oder
aber da ist immer so zieht der sohn
nutzer zu kunst vom ertrag der
reifensituation erstellen die
notsituation als argument reicht
natürlich nicht aus um eine
baubewilligung zu erhalten
doch harke ist gut vorbereitet max
blöchlinger und alle anderen vertreter
des kantons st gallen lassen sich vom
projekt überzeugen
die sitzung endet mit dem versprechen
der behörden das bewilligungsverfahren
beschleunigt zu behandeln
[Musik]
so langsam scheint sich sein leben
wieder zu normalisieren mit der
musikgesellschaft lockt wie fühlt sich
peter haag aufs engste verbunden
seine lebenspartnerin marianne knöpfen
lernte er übrigens in dieser
gemeinschaft kennen
[Musik]
der erste bagger rollt im februar 2013
über die wiese auf der schon bald ein
neubau stehen soll
der unternehmer hat die baubewilligung
erhalten und zu steht dem spatenstich
nichts mehr im wege
damen haben
auf der baustelle eine unfallfreie
baustelle alles gute also in diesem
sinne
nach all der zeit und der oktober
gemacht haben die show ganz spezieller
moment
riesenfreude dass man jetzt sagt
schafften es auch schnell die planung
vertrieb und jetzt wirken können staaten
[Musik]
in den ersten märztagen wird diskutiert
stadt gebaut
hans peter eberle bauverwalter der
gemeinde steiner hat einen baustopp
bewirkt auslöser war der aufgeweichte
zufahrtsweg wenn das problem die gaben
sich mein straßen sind noch verschmutzt
und bevölkerung mit den aus der
förderung erfahren ein fleck jato im
schnitt es aber freut das nicht ist das
ganze mit dem nächsten regen gott wir
haben sie schlagen noch lange bewiesen
schlamm san marino und mehr noch einfach
per mail bestellen ganze und das kann
sein damit sie das wenn man baustellen
hat dass man auch einfach finanziert
denn wo bauer wie obwohl jetzt wo so
viel wie hat wiederum geld ist natürlich
das haben was man geschafft hat also
dass ich anderen unternehmen
der risikorat main gebiet oder das ist
immer zu jeder zeit team und die meisten
stören weder die diskussion aber das
kann und schlossen so dass eine alles
verschmutzen sagt ihr euch zu spüren
dafür auch wirklich ja vernehmen weil
ich nicht weg ich werde auch eine fesche
machen es ist stark die wahl stellen und
der garten aber ich meinte wenn wir
immer so gemacht oder so dass man aus
wenn wir das mit probenmaterial macht
oder wesentliches material das man einer
philine verschmutzen friedloser trägt
also mit den stichworten wenig direkte
sich der erhebung
die lösung ist ein kies belag der einige
tausend franken kostet und den haag
selber berappen muss nebst dem baustopp
gibt es einen weiteren grund für
verzögerung der ganze boden muss
angehoben werden
hochwasserschutz dazu braucht es festes
material damit der neubau auf ein
stabiles fundament zu stehen kommt da
immer ganz großes problem mit dem
material der lieferant oder material
liefert etwa chips falsches braucht wo
es kaffee steht wo schlammig ist dann
wenn wir uns einen teil wieder abführen
und da hat man natürlich jahren hat er
sich mal so western und ja ich würde
sagen jetzt dass man da immer wieder
verzögerungen wegen dem jetzt merkt man
schon zum teil des batterie als in new
york und das gefühl kann man nicht
planen innerhalb von drei minuten da
fangen und zum teil auf solche ziel kann
definitiv einfach zu viele sachen noch
nicht geregelt sind und bekommen
entwickler machen ja wäre dann alle
inhalte merkmale ja kein mensch das
einfach das mit viel wert
[Musik]
wenn der april gibt es erneut ärger auf
der baustelle weil der boden zu weich
ist soll das gebäude auf pfählen
abgestützt werden
doch bei einigen stimmte abstand nicht
da stehen november an den start gegangen
doch das verstanden die nerven liegen
blank
dass die pfähle falsch gesetzt sind ist
nicht das einzige problem
170 pfeiler wurden außerdem zu tief in
den boden gerammt diese müssen nun stück
um stück verlängert werden wertvolle
zeit verloren geht der bauherr redet
allen beteiligten ins gewissen
verschiedenes cover ist einfach absolut
gepasst und war mehr vor allem eine
basta abgemacht die stofftiere baustelle
die kalte wird die meinen dass man
besser mit dem fall der mauer bekannt
dass sich behinderte zu verdienen sind
viele zeit auch endgültigen terminplan
wo einfach einen terminplan schon 14
tage westermann dass der ball meister am
und eigentlich gang zum solche gala und
der könnte ja selber angewendet ohne
lokale selber dass man da nicht schaffen
geschafft werde passieren fehler aber
mussten sie zusammen mache ich einfach
viel zu viel und diese zu mindestens
zwei wochen wieder verzug gehe und nach
einem monat buchen
[Musik]
es ist juni
und eigentlich hätte um diese zeit das
auf richtfest des neubaus stattfinden
sollen die bauarbeiten sind drei monate
in verzug
verzögerungen gab es auch weil es
wochenlang geregnet hatte da es arbeitet
die kann halt nur machen wenn sie wieder
brauche nicht und da heißt immer wieder
unterbricht eg und die ja mit der
maschine sind natürlich genau wie der
weggang eine andere baustelle wenn man
dort könne weitermachen und denn jetzt
sind auch nicht wieder parat sie zum
wiederaufbau von dem her einfach die
fahrzeuge der unternehmer geht mit dem
8,8 millionen bau ein risiko ein
er rechnet jedoch damit schweizweit
einer der größten händler für holz zu
werden um das zu erreichen muss die
firma den jahresumsatz von 12 millionen
steigern
deshalb will haag einen außendienst
mitarbeiter einstellen er denkt dabei an
seinen alten bekannten rolf müller
ich würde gern mal als kapitän ersetzen
der stelle
die idee ist eigentlich dass man noch
guten hier arbeitet dass du noch einen
überstehen kundenbetreuung mit neue
unterlagen und dass man regelmäßig
unsere hunde für das bis zweimal im jahr
soll dazu hatte mit seiner osterdienstag
denke genau damit war die dem job doch
noch ihren schritt im rai betreut und
weiter denken es ist zwar ein größeres
gebiet aber was ist eigentlich gelegen
mitdenken vor sich so ist das sehr gut
da war mir riesig frage wenn man nach
einer mache mit ihnen und dann wirst du
innerhalb von 14 tagen melden
rivalität da rolf müller wird die chance
packen und das team auf acht mitarbeiter
ergänzen
[Musik]
mitte september 2013 steht der rohbau
endlich das herzstück des betriebes ist
die lagerhalle mit dem 1,5 millionen
teuren bedienungs gerät können ganze
holz pakete in hoch gelegene regale
geschoben werden
[Musik]
und so endet diese geschichte mit dem
aufrichte fest ein anlass für all jene
die geholfen haben das neue glück zu
erschaffen
[Musik]
vom schicksalsschlag wollte er sich
nicht unterkriegen lassen
vielmehr nahm peter haag sein leben in
die hand und bahnte sich so einen neuen
weg in die zukunft und dass wir wieder
gut dabei staaten wieder können schaffen
wir noch viel besser funktioniert
hervorragend
[Musik]